To send Marla's record to Dr. Jones, Dr.
Johnson uses the direct service
provided by his state HIE.
This simplified and somewhat futuristic
diagram explains how that could work.
Here Marla's record has a share button.
That's not quite available yet but some
EMR vendors are working on integrating
direct into their workflow so
it may appear in the future.
Doctor Johnson clicks it and
selects Doctor Jones from
a list of his usual referrals.
If needed he could could look up a new
physician in a directory provided by
the direct server called a Health ISP or
HISP.
Here, for simplicity,
we're assuming that Doctor Johnson and
Doctor Jones are using the same HISP.
Before physicians are listed,
their identities and
qualifications are verified, and they're
assigned a special direct email address.
This establishes trust so Dr.
Johnson knows the email
will only go to Dr. Jones.
The form of the record can be
whatever Dr. Johnson chooses.
It could be a scan of a paper record or
it could be a special XML formatted
patient summary specified under VDT.
In any case, the record is encrypted and
attached to a secure email.
This establishes security so the
information can't be viewed in transit,
a key requirement for
health information exchange.
Privacy was taken care of when Marla
consented to sharing of her record
with other physicians
involved in her care.
If you've ever signed a HIPAA release
in your doctor's waiting room,
you agreed to this.
Dr. Jones gets the email
in her direct inbox and
can review the record if it's a PDF or
paper scan.
If it is in a special XML format called
a Continuity of Care Document or
CCD, the record could be parsed and
put right into Marla's chart in Dr.
Jones's office as shown here.
Parsing it and merging it into
an existing record is yet
another futuristic
component of this diagram.
Note that the encryption and
decryption of Marla's record is
done using public key encryption.
We'll look at how that
works in lesson four.